I think we've got a live picture coming
from Spain this is just from Madrid and
you can see there Tom just beginning to
encroach on the top edge they outline of
the moon so it's just beginning it's
just beginning to move across the face
of the Sun it's a lovely image there and
you know what you're seeing something
worth remembering when you look at
images like this is your actual that we
don't often see which is not just in the
new moon so the moon that occurs every
lunar month but we never see it for the
page it's as close to know that having
for 18 years is that correct the current
points the moon is that them it's not
actually closer than it has been for 18
years but it is a closed point in its
orbit right it is that a closed point in
its orbit so it is what we call a super
moon it's also a new moon it's when the
moon the Sun and the earth are lining up
in the sky but this is actually such a
perfect alignment and astronomy we have
a special word for it we call it a
scissor g.g when these read that word I
was lacking confidence when it
connection so thank you that's right
sister GTA and that's what we're seeing
beginning to happen there in Spain it's
a lovely image there and as that happens
as it continues to do so spain and then
places all around europe are going to
see a really spectacular solar eclipse